hoy Brasil va a vivir un día histórico
porque el Tribunal Superior electoral
tiene que decidir si el expresidente
Jair bolsonaro va a ser declarado
inegible es decir no va a poderse
presentar en las próximas elecciones la
razón una reunión que bolsonaro mantuvo
el año pasado en vísperas de las
elecciones presidenciales con más de 50
diplomáticos extranjeros en la que sin
aportar pruebas crítico el
funcionamiento del voto electrónico de
las urnas dejando una serie de dudas
sobre el funcionamiento del sistema
electoral en Brasil va a ser una jornada
larga porque hay seis jueces que van a
tener que votar además el día se abre
con la lectura de un informe de más de
40 páginas y sabemos por filtraciones a
la prensa local que solamente el voto
del primer juez tiene 300 páginas están
previstas tres fechas para este juicio
de suma importancia hoy el 27 y el 29 de
junio y además cualquier juez puede
pedir lo que se llama una vista es decir
un período de reflexión que va de 30 a
60 días Por lo tanto es posible que hoy
no sepamos Cuál es la decisión de los
seis jueces sabemos que en el tribunal
en este tribunal en este momento está
Alexandre dimoráis el juez de supremo
considerado el archienemigo de bolsonaro
pero también está lunes martes el juez
evangélico al que bolsonaro nombró para
el supremo habrá que ver cuál es la
decisión de un lunes martes si pide más
tiempo o no Porque parece que la
decisión ya está tomada y hay presiones
dentro de la derecha para que bolsonaro
ya pase páginas ya que se cree que no va
a poder ser salvado por ninguna decisión
judicial ya se pueda emplacar el nuevo
nombre de la derecha para las próximas
elecciones de 2026 en un país que vive
permanentemente en precampaña electoral